that's good what a monkey yeah who would  win in a wrestling match between happy  George in you yo easily happy George you  were actually for the first time smaller  than somebody in a film I know I know my  ego does not like that George sure yeah  it's big but George is bigger keep  looking up at everybody now I know what  Kevin Hart his life is like yes what  [Music]  George Clooney I feel like he's  smoulders like when he's brushing his  teeth and small ders I  the tests my true nerd dump I mean I  think I have to go with my George as I  know I'm better I've never met George  Lucas well you're never gonna meet him  now after saying that no I guess not I  guess I ruined that dream  you